تاخذوا في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضه القمه
الثالثه والاربعون لقاده دولي مجلس
التعاون الخليجي
القمه الخليجيه الصينيه للتعاون والتنميه
والتي سيشارك فيها قاده دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي والرئيس الصيني
بمشاركه قاده دول عربيه والرئيس الصيني
وكانت السعوديه والصين اكدتها في بيان
مشترك كصدر في ختام القمه السعوديه
الصينيه التي عقدت امس في الرياض اكدت على
بذل جهود مشتركه في الدفاع عن مبدا عدم
التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
واستقرار الامدادات الغذائيه من القمح
والحبوب لجميع دول العالم وعدم انقطاعها
والحفاظ على وفره المعروف واستقرار
الاسعار
في مجال الاستخدامات السلميه للطاقه
النوويه
تعزيز التعاون المشترك لضمان سلميه برنامج
ايران النووي
ودعايات وهران للتعاونين مع الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه واحترام مبادئ حسن
الجوار
كما اكد دعمهم الكامل للجهود الراميه
للتوصل الى حل سياسيا للازمه اليمنيه وفقا
للمبادره الخليجيه
على تطوير التنسيق والتعاون في المجالات
الدفاعيه وتعزيز تعاون وتنسيق الجهود
وتبادل الخبرات في مجالات الانذار
الاستخباراتى
القمه السعوديه الصينيه التي عقدت في
الرياض حيث ارتقاء الرئيس الصيني
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان
وتجاوزت قيمه الاتفاقيات التي وقعت تسعه
وعشرين مليار دولار امريكي
وكان ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان والرئيس الصيني في جيم بنك عقد جلسه
موحادثات رسميه جرى خلالها استعراض واوجه
التعاون بين البلدين والجهود التنسيقيه
المشتركه لتعزيز التعاوني في مختلف
المجالات
مراسله الجزيره بدر ربيعان ومن المركز
الاعلامي للقمه في الرياض ايضا مراسله
الجزيره شيماء
بدر بالحديث عن قمه دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي والقنه
الخليجيه الصينيه اضافه الى القمه العربيه
الصينيه ماذا همم او ماذا في اهم بنود
جدول للاعمال في هذه القمه
نعم حسن ما زلنا في انتظار وصول قاده دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي لبدء انعقاد الدوره
الثالثه والاربعين للقمه التي تجمع القاده
اليوم هنا والتي ستبحث عدد من الملفات ذات
الاتمام المشترك والموقف الجمعي تجاه بعض
الملفات الدوليه يفصلنا تقريبا نصف ساعه
من الان متوقع ايضا ان يعلن خلال القمه
امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم ال ثاني عن
استضافه دوله قطر لاعمال الدوره المقبله
من قمه الخليج في الدوحه بعدها سينظم
الرئيس الصيني بالتالي او ست الحقد القمه
خليجيه الصينيه التي يعنون لها التعاون
والتنميه وهذا اشاره الى ان الملف
الاقتصادي والمحور الاقتصادي والمسيطر على
جدول واعمال هذه القمم الثلاثه والتي بدات
منذ يوم امس في قمه السعوديه اليوم ايضا
تم خليجيه الصينيه وقمه عربيه صينيه
شاهدنا هذا التوقي عدد من الاتفاقيات
وثيقه الشرك الاستراتيجيه بين السعوديه
والصين وكذلك خطه ما بين رؤيه المملكه 20
30 ومبادره الحزام والطريق همم الصينيه
اذا قمه خليجيه صينيه تنطلق بعد قليل
بعدها سينضم الرئيس الصيني الى همم قاد
الدول الخليج لبدل القمه الخليجيه الصينيه
بعد هذه القمه سينظم جميع القاده
الخليجيون والعرب 16 دوله اضافه الى
الرئيس الصيني في قمه عربيه صينيه تحاول
الدخول الى البوابه الى الى البوابه
العربيه والافريقيه من خلال قمم الرياضه
التي تعقيدها اليوم لاحقا من المقرر ان
سيعقد مؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان في همم مقر
هذه القمه
يعني اكثر من قمه واكثر من رساله كذلك
بوجود الصين هذه المره بهذا الحضور اللافت
متمثله برئها ما هو
الموضوع الابرز والرساله الابرز التي
تبعثها الصين من خلال هذا التواجد في
الرياض
نعم ليله لفهمها الرسائل التي تريد الصين
ان تبعثها من خلالها تواجدها هنا في
الرياض وهذا الزخم الكبير من القمم ثلاث
قمم خلال اليومين فقط يمكن ان نطرح سؤالين
السؤال الاول لماذا هذا التوقيت ثم ما
الذي تريده الصين بالنسبه للسؤال الاول
هذا التوقيت هو التوقيت السياسي مهم وحساس
جدا بالنسبه للصين الداخليه نتحدث عن اشهر
قليله منذ ان قام الرئيس سجين بتعزيز
مكانته امينا عمل للحزب الشيوعيه الصناعي
الحكم للمره الثالثه على التوالي لمده خمس
سنوات مقبله في اكتوبر الماضي تفصلنا ايضا
اشهر قليل عن تعزيز مكانته رئيسا لولايه
الثالثه في مارس اثار المقبل اذا هي فتره
حساسه جدا بالاضافه الى ان الرئيس الصيني
بعد تعزيز مكانته الداخليه يريد ان يقوم
بتعزيز ما كانت الصين اقتصاديا وتجاريا
حول العالم هنا الانظار تتوجه الى دول
الخليج العالم العربي ودمى دول شمال
افريقيا دول افريقيا عموما مع نظره
ومبادره الحزام والطريقه التي اطلقها
الرئيس الصينيشين في عام 2015 اذا ما الذي
يريد شيء من هذه الزياره الرئيس الصيني
شيء يطمح الى ان يتم التعامل خلال
التبادلات التجاريه في الفتره المقبله
سواء مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه او مع
دول الخليج باعتبار السعوديه هي اكبر مصدر
النفط الخام بمعدل مليونير يوميا للصين
تريد ان تتم هذه المعاملات في المستقبل
العمله الصينيه مستقبلا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كان قد قلت لك تركت الباب
مواريبا هذه المساله الى جانب مساله النفط
والتبادلات التجاريه الصيني هنالك ايضا
ملف الامن البيانات كانت الصين قد اطلقت
مبادره امن البيانات خلال السنوات الماضيه
وتقول انه الى حد الان هنالك مشاركه هامه
من الدول العربيه نحو 17 دوله تشارك في
هذه المبادره الى جانب هذا الملف ايضا
هنالك ملف الاستثمارات ربما هو من ابرز
الم الذي يريد شيء طرحه هنا والحصول على
اتفاقيات وشركات مع الدول الخليجيه
والعربيه كون ملف الاستثمارات هو ملف
اساسي ورئيسي في مبادره الحزام والطريق
الصينيه يريد شيئا يعزز مكانه الشركات
الصينيه للاستثمار في تشييد البنيه
التحتيه للدول العربيه خاصه دول الخليج
على سبيل المثال ملعب لوسين في قطر تم
تشيده بالشراكه مع شركات الصينيه الصين
هنا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه تطمح الى
ان يكون لها موت قدم في تشييد مدينه نيوم
السعوديه المدينه الذكيه ضمن رؤيه
السعوديه الطموح 2030 اذا هنالك ملفات عده
تريد الصين طرحه هنا وتريد الحصول على
اتفاقيات تضمن لها مستقبل كبير في
التبادلات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه مع دول
الخليج والدول على العربيه ايضا التي سيتم
نقاشها خلال القمه الصينيه العربيه لاول
مره هذا اليوم ليله كل هذه الملفات طبعا
كما ذكرنا تاتي في توقيت حس بالنسبه للصين
يطمحشي الى ان يكون له دور فعال في تعزيز
مكانه الصين اقتصاديا ليس فقط كساني اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم بلتا منافس الرئيسي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في المنطقه
العربيه تحديدا وقت حساسه للصين وايضا وقت
حساس لدول المنطقه على العموم سنتابع
مجريات هذه القمم خلال ساعات النهار
المقبله شكرا جزيلا لكما شيماء
شكرا جزيلا لبدر الربيعان من الرياض